au petit matin sur ce site exceptionnel
du foyer de charité sur les hauteurs de
trinité le silence n'est rompue que par
les louanges qui ouvre la première messe
[Musique]
si la retraite spirituelle est ouverte à
tous indépendamment des confessions la
grande majorité des pensionnaires est
venu chercher la même chose
un rapprochement avec le christ quand on
passe une année avec eux
vous devez bousculés par des événements
heureux ou malheureux
on a un besoin de se ressourcer de ce
projet d'un jeu driver dans cette foi
chrétienne que nous avons et donc c'est
le moment de faire le point avec nous
mêmes de nous recentrer sur l'essentiel
et j'avais envie de me retirer un peu de
restaurer on dira et j'ai choisi de
faire cette retraite pour ce que le
seigneur nous a donné quand même une vie
nous a donné beaucoup de choses donc
pour moi c'est un moyen de le remercier
et puis d'être en silence pendant ces 6
jours et donc j'en avais vraiment besoin
le silence c'est l'une des composantes
essentielles de la retraite spirituelle
après la messe place au petit déjeuner
sans conversation aucune histoire de ne
pas perturber la réflexion et le
cheminement des uns et des autres
c'est l'occasion pour les oreilles d or
de se retrouver ensemble et de se dire
on va simplement rendre grâce tout ce
que nous avons eu tout au long de
l'année parce qu'il ya eu
nous avons traversée
des moments plus difficiles mais il ya
aussi des joies il a new delhi 106 lits
à lui vraiment des choses qui nous ont
permis d'avancer et donc c'est
l'occasion de reconnaître que dieu est
infidèle dans chaque chose chaque
événement cette soirée de la
saint-sylvestre la soixantaine de
retraitants bas donc la passe et tout en
louanges est en adoration pour terminer
l'année 2018 et commencer l'année 2019
en approfondissant sa foi loin très loin
des soirées festives et souvent bien
arrosées
ces matières spiritualité qu'on soit
dans l'axé ou pas dans l'excès ou
comment de quelques façons compass le
truc on est toujours dans la
spiritualité c'est dans la joie la bonne
humeur de la bonne entente c'est avec le
sourire et sans les problèmes sans se
fâcher dans l'amour avec offrir de la
série n'a pas de soucis on passerait une
pole à nous pour tout le monde de
pouvoir recevoir dieu en toute plénitude
on a besoin du silence pour ça on a
besoin du ciment s'est pour sa part ce
que j'en ai fait une année dernière et
c'est vrai que je m'attendais pas qu'il
fallait faire le silence je n'ai pas
compris cette année j'ai compris
effectivement on a besoin du silence
pour se
comment dire ce ne soit pas le terme
mais bon pour soit retrouvé voilà c'est
ça qu'on se retrouver quelques jours de
méditation dans le calme au foyer de la
charité les retraites se présentent
comme des haltes pour le coeur et
l'esprit